sur l'île de la Réunion situé sur un
point chaud la terre déverse
régulièrement au gré de ses caprices de
la roche en
fusion la lave à peine refroidie en
surface commence à se
dégrader de petites mousses et deliken
s'installe rapidement et participe
activement à ce travail
d'érosion dans les débris de feuilles et
de roches les nombreuses graines
apportées par le balai incessant des
oiseaux vont
germer parmi les premiers arbres à
pouvoir s'installer dans ces conditions
extrêmes le bois de fer bâard s'impose
comme un redoutable
pionnier il va plonger ses racines dans
les maigres fissures qui sisaillent la
roche profitant de quelques ressources
our présente apportant une grosse
quantité de biomasse et accompagné de
quelques autres offrir l'ombre
nécessaire à l'installation de nouvelles
espèces créant les prémises de la
forêt c'est un arbre qui mesure de 5 à 8
m de haut les branches sont tortueus et
ramassé les feuilles d'un beau vert
foncé sont oval arrondis au bout
épaisses et coriass signe de résistance
à la
sécheresse toute la plante possède du
latex
blanc à partir du mois de novembre et ce
jusqu'au mois de février de petites
fleurs hermaphrodites apparaissent à
l'isselle des feuilles et sur la partie
défeuillée des
Rameaux
elle pousse en petite grappe finement
ciselé et d'un mauve
exquis une fois fécondé de petits fruits
ovoïd vont se former ils vont grossir et
atteindre la taille d'une
olive
il n'est pas rare de voir des grappes de
fruits dressé au bout des
branches ils vont mûir en prenant une
belle teinte presque noire et
brillante ils contiennent eux aussi une
grande quantité de latex
blanc là encore les oiseaux jouent un
rôle prépondérant dans la dispersion de
la grosse graine contenue dans chaque
fruit une fois de plus la nature a su se
doter d'une espèce capable de produire
un grand nombre de graines capable de
voyager afin d'atteindre de nouveaux
rivages et de prospérer de s'adapter et
de se
reproduire